thanks yasar yes indeed we do have a
very special guest The Mastermind behind
the grand chess tour and the 13th world
champion Mr Gary Casper of Gary first of
all welcome back to the show I've seen
you last time in Poland now we're in
Croatia it seems like everywhere the
granchester goes there's so much love
absolutely
but I'm so happy now we have Traditions
Bucharest Warsaw Zagreb and of course
you know we everything will end up in St
Louis yes yeah uh but yeah it's it's a
traditional year and I think it was
spectacular opening so I believe
yesterday absolutely absolutely I mean
look 45 minutes live front prime time so
it's this on national TV and I was a
prime minister and members of the
government you know attending and I
think it was phenomenal yeah and I mean
that's it shows that you know chess
could also you know offer value for a
sponsor yeah so it's not just you know
charity it's it's a big deal and uh I
think the Superman is happy and uh
best place ever happy because the
standards are very high I mean you just
you
you could see that chess is the game
that received respect it deserves
absolutely and every single Ballroom
that we go to it gets filled in Romania
it was filled in Poland I mean oh my God
what was uh what was many more people
falling yes now it's like it or not but
it's the most prestigious tournament in
the network in the world and now with
Magnus you know dropping out of official
cycle and uh participating in in
granchester so that definitely adds you
know Prestige to our event speaking of
one participant in the grandchester is
Duda who's been having a pretty decent
year he did well in Bucharest he did
very well on home turf in Poland and
right now what a great start against
Nepal with the black pieces of Victory
yes yes it's just it's
missed the moment because the position
was not great but uh but nothing just
the
and this is from my perspective I mean
there's nothing was indicating that it
was such a disaster for for for Nepal so
quickly in fact it seemed like he had a
better preparation he got the scotch on
yes I know on the board prepared but I
just you know it's the he played very
either it was was it exhibited
confidence but I wasn't sure why you're
so confident I mean just because the way
I understand chess it's it's it's you
know it didn't tell me that his position
was so great so it was yeah because
black had a solid position in the center
C5 Pawn is is
a questionable Pawn H5
yeah and this was the mistake you know
as my late coach and then the kitten
said you know in this position so H5 the
best move forward H4
H2O
yeah and this seems to be uh sort of
what led to his demise this Pawn on H5
became a weakness later on but we still
have some games going on Magnus seems to
be doing quite well he didn't do well in
the beginning in Poland after that we
were discussing at some point and we
weren't really still thinking
he did he did he did come back it's a
Pity that he just he plays here only you
know
um
uh has a wild card on the full
participant of the tour so he'll be
still you know Mississippi Lewis but
again since his performance in Warsaw
and was was outstanding okay the the
bullets built section of that yeah yeah
uh and let's see what happens happens
here but again is is undoubtedly easily
a favorite you've been uh gauging their
Vibes at the opening ceremony you talked
with Magnus quite extensively you were
talking with nepo as well who did you
feel was in the best shape or in the
best mood
oh my goose is is relaxed now so that's
why I guess was that we never know yeah
just you know is but I think it's it's
hard now but he understands you know
he's you know
he's a sensitive man and obviously you
know this horrible War and the fact is
that he's you know even technically he's
just he's I know how you feel being
Russian especially you know if you stay
there so and I think it has pressure it
puts pressure yeah he he knows that he
he somehow also shares his Collective
responsibility for this heinous crimes
committed in Ukraine so that's why I
think it's difficult for him to play
definitely feels like there's some
psychological pressure on on Apple right
now we're hoping that he's going to show
his best self in this tournament but
let's discuss this position I mean is
there anything to discuss exactly at
this point
I'm you know I'm puzzled by the opening
choice because as we discussed it
briefly just uh that's the uh the idea
this this is that the black should play
D5 instead of exchanging on D4 that's
that's that's the late 80s early 90s
because when I started playing chess so
this is in the 70s that's that was kind
of what it's it's a type CD4 CD for D5
e594 and then Knight C3 so I remember I
just I played it in in in
tournaments as a kid typically we're for
black pieces yeah so that was when and
then you know just was the discovery
that we can play D5 and I think this was
a kind of consultation game I played
after match was Nigel 93 on stage so and
I played with someone against Nigel and
someone and we played D5 and I think
they took they was got a surprise took
on D5 who played some kind of C4 but
it's not not good so the right before
594 and and I remember I played it this
was to get shirov
says I think
and
2002 probably isn't it yeah and I I took
on C6
and uh after day five yeah uh actually
it might be my maybe maybe even one was
when my I mean assuming that I was maybe
it was being my last night
I don't just want one of them I'm not
sure which one yeah yes this is the I
took on C6 and no no no no if I if 594
yes and then to take on C6 and that bd2
that's the yeah that's the
and then this is black would take one I
think should have played Bishop with
five here and things I think so but I'm
not here I'm not sure already but but
Bishop is three is just you know it's
it's I mean it's very ambitious you want
to trap the Knight but it just it
doesn't it doesn't look
I might just play very quickly yes
knight bd2 uh Bishop F5 and I look
Knight B3 I don't know it's this could
you try to play Knight F1 here because
the idea is actually to trap the Knight
on D4 yeah so another one you know this
is then maybe F6 because now now I want
to do this the same night as four three
but it was night not on B3 just put on
F1 much better place exactly much better
show up on E3 or somewhere without maybe
maybe have six here but again the six is
just still there's this stuff the F6 is
not what's the next move yeah actually
I'm not sure what's a white snacks move
Blackberry G5
also white snakes was still a very
complex and I'm sure Magnus was aware of
yeah yeah he was playing very very
confidently he started this for the
World Championships yes yes and he
played B6 provoking Knight H4 provoking
in ih4 cutting this Knight and a free G5
yeah but it's the that's
so so one-sided yeah so white squares
yeah
very nice game so far and I think we we
still have a few moves we're just about
to potentially see resignation yeah a
few moves very few years
this might be a resignation time Bishop
G3 to defends
yeah I think this is
and let's see Gucci has 30 seconds
let's see the resignation yeah it's a
video yeah
slow start for gokish pod we kind of
seen him do that often look you know we
just it's his first his first event
in the branches were in the branches too
yeah first time he gets the Wild Card
yeah exactly definitely a big moment for
him exactly that's this
do you think there's some pressure he's
feeling some pressure
and the first first the first game you
play with animals
what do you think yeah yeah probably
yeah he definitely has this cool car
collected look on his face but inside of
him there must be a fire burning
isn't queen of form just mate we have
three
G6
yeah yeah no this one Rook F3
he's still fighting he's a fighter that
is
there we go we have a handshake in this
one great start for for Magnus
um
one of the it's so strange to call him a
wildcard yeah he's so good he he stole
13 branches through points in in Poland
he's going to try to do safe still yeah
yes it's uh it's difficult to call him a
wild card
let's see what do we have another one of
uh
this is not doing badly yes oh yes oh
man yeah those are still the business
for sure yeah yeah he has some chances
but just to stay on this one because
Richie only has a few seconds left I
know most position a bit with 97
actually
so he's back to move 97 is coming
um that is coming anyway how do you
defend against 97 comes anyway no yes
you do yes yeah it's probably a draw
maybe Rook E6
you can go crazy
things I like this
is Queen C7
first person
it doesn't matter that 97 still 9606
F1
20 seconds for Fabian also this one is
turning into
oh Blitz okay
I remember in Poland we had one of these
games xf6
25 night
another four yeah that's easy doesn't
really mean it could not afford the 93
attacks of two just you know to just to
avoid yes coming off another phone at
this rate just you know another four
maybe we should be six years instead
Queen still yes
there's still something
it's a dead draw I don't understand
I would be very surprised because I see
okay technically yeah you can definitely
try to play an E3
that's another
maybe 93 was a bit ambitious yeah you go
with 95 back now
and then he plays G5
okay yeah it's it's okay but you don't
do
you can take knight from D5 to F1 I mean
it doesn't come on that's the it's you
had score on the F4 Square I mean very
good Square for the night yeah yeah and
we have another result to look less
versus sarich has finished that's how
you lose
G5 yeah maybe it's not still another
form it's still dropping maybe now I
have H4 not H4 now H4 plan H4 at the
draw yeah
yes yes
is it
yes he sees it
yeah Bobby had some chances
um no more chances but and this one I
believe it's a dry as well yes alireza
this is a true battle of generations
it is true
the final game
do you think Richie at some point starts
playing for a win
I mean serious serious this is a break
win what what can you do it's not on the
phone yeah yeah it's probably not going
to happen
so that's the it's the I don't think
look in theory you should be careful
because you know this is you have to
probably move the king when I suggest
you know
three
because this is in theory Bishop goes
Queen goes in F2 now G1 but then King
goes on h2h result yeah yeah
yeah actually the sea pointers though
players definitely realize that
perhaps soon
okay inviting caption
ing
yeah too which is it creates no threats
ah okay nowhere with no threats yeah
yeah so let's see foreign
and then night World from H2 to
no maybe maybe you're right so this is
this I'm not sure you want to put the
queen on G1
don't let the Knight
correct yes make sure night doesn't go
away because if Knights
show up sometimes on F5 somewhere you
may have a little challenge yes it's not
even the five King on H3 so
we've uh we've seen this type of
imbalances go wrong for the queen
five now yeah
some Queen H7 ideas yeah but that still
is the yeah
yeah Check Yes but kingy King G5
probably
um
to block and then prepare
yeah it's difficult to take the night
out
yeah that's the question will he get
overly ambitious by the way he made that
move with two seconds
protected the pool
definitely feels like
it's like
before we should start just to forget
but don't get too ambitious make it
Perpetual make a perpetual
I think Richard is starting to play for
a win right now what the queen he said
well I can just equal seven check from
the H4 Queen and five chairs King F6 for
the price and then and then just you
know eventually
not the greatest idea
everything you see contacted for a while
engage eight
good after just now Knight is really
neither five do they tell you that goes
on F5 93 and then Knight goes on F5 I'm
going for it yeah this is the question
is Kennedy Perpetual of the queen E2
this is much more difficult than it
should have been should have ever been
yes neither five now Queen H5 Knight H4
is still everything protected he's
they've protected and Knight goes and
that's when Knight goes on F5
foreign
five now
yeah
the question
before all the movies
not to lose the peace
22.4 yes
and then he should decide maybe like
English right now
immediately yeah
okay 25.
should you take on D6 because that then
it's a draw but if you can actually
you can just
for me
it's made
King G4 Rook H2 is also this made yes
the fruit goes a file is made yeah
that's that's why I'm just you know I
think as a student and you don't have
chance yeah this is a real threat right
now I think Rock H2 is over if you don't
we don't pay attention what is this
what is happening wow
no
wow
this is over
wow and they're smiling as well oh my
goodness you could have taken policy
three five times so you don't want to
take this yes
is a very solid position as usual uh
pleasure to have you here commentate the
games with us tell us a bit about the
grand chess tour okay let's uh The Show
Goes On yeah we'll see you in the next
couple of days of course I'm around
and right now we're going to go on a
short commercial break and we'll be back
shortly with round two